the answer you're giving is no because
because the only the only right answer
if I said a guy who's judgment you could
trust I didn't say just anyone I said
who's judgment you can trust and you
said it depends and that that's
indicating that you can't trust them
even even back in the day if when they
needed to receive the approval uh that's
what proven guys who beat the women or
cheat on the women that have baby
mothers so that's not that's not true by
and large that's what it's still a
reality that's not her exceptions but it
wasn't the rules that your view on men
my view is that your view on met all the
men throughout history were just beating
their women no I never said that no I
know but that's what you're implying
when you say things when you say when
you say when we're talking when we're
when we're talking about a general rule
and you're saying oh but they approve
things like beating their mothers you're
you're saying that like it's common and
the words we use are important and so
like it was acceptable to a certain
extent and it was hidden
so there was a lot so that is your view
on men no it's not right men it's just
what happened is okay but reality okay
but that's your view on Matt what data
do you have to support that no no I'm
saying what what data do you have to
support that that was relevant that that
happened all the time what data I never
said all the time I said there were men
out there proven guys that had this
background okay would you say it was
happening by and large
that was a common thing no the way
you're trying to generalize and I'm just
saying that it still happened and I
still remember but exceptions don't make
the rule but there's no such thing as
rules rules rules are meant to be broken
what do you mean there's no you don't
think there's you don't think there's
any generalities in society like some
things are just yeah but does that mean
they're supposed to be followed no
no but then then people wouldn't get
together if if if everyone was the
exception it's not the exception then
people just wouldn't get together you
can't say anything yeah if we can't
agree that there are General things in
society we can't have a conversation
about is that the base of life just to
procreate and get with people then no
but no we but we're just saying in-laws
kind of yeah yeah I mean it's saying
when when people when the girls were
saying like oh I dress for me I dress
for I dress for myself I think that
makes no sense right because if you were
the only person on the planet like the
only person you wouldn't bother putting
on makeup or anything like that you it
literally makes zero sense it just let a
girl go out for a week yeah or let's say
a month and get no attention but she'll
end up butt naked in the streets
I feel as though sometimes like our our
perception of like men and women are
um different or that like you people
haven't met a woman that's like
um feels naturally confident in like her
natural beauty or
um doesn't seek Mel's attention and I
feel as though even though it may be
like the exception like people don't
necessarily come into contact with that
type of woman hence why like the example
is cap or it's like because because
then she wouldn't wear makeup in your
natural beauty no one would like like my
wife doesn't wear makeup but my point is
like yours even if it's not for guys
attention it might be because you want
to look pretty for other girls but then
why are you trying to why are you trying
to one-up yourself over other girls why
are you trying to beautify yourself come
compared to the rest of the world and
men do it as well but men just do it in
different ways right so we we are always
trying to get a better job or better we
speak about so it's like a man will
happily say that I do XYZ for a woman
but if a woman to say in the reverse
he's like no I do it for me I do it for
this I did for that in reality no
thought that you have is original so
everything we see is regurgitate
information so it's actually impossible
to not be influenced by the people
around you yet a woman starts to say I
do it for me when it's virtually
impossible it makes zero sense
it doesn't mean that there isn't things
that women do for men there are things
just like say that then don't be like
for me it also doesn't mean that a girl
doesn't dress up or put on makeup for
self-love for herself yeah exactly self
love self-care
you're telling me the girls at carnival
walking around in a thong are just doing
it for themselves
the Masquerade people because that's
different that's part of the costumes
so wait why is it acceptable in Brazil
for girls to be wearing the thongs and
it's everyone and everything culture I
mean that's the culture that they find
attractive we're not in Brazil why are
we talking about Brazil
[Laughter]
it's like we go out of our way to find
like the craziest craziest exceptions
why I just feel like because they exist
yeah I know but we're not saying they
don't exist but we don't but okay let me
finish okay I think as a grown adults we
can agree that there are exceptions to
every rule but we can make statements
based on General tendencies in society
without having to stay with every
statement there's an exception I think
we can just know I I also think it's a
dream it's like it's like me saying like
uh I can run 100 meters in nine seconds
it's like and it's like
I can't but you're like oh but Usain
Bolt run it in nine seconds so why can't
I run it in nine seconds or if I say men
men are generally taller than women and
then you point to the one guy that isn't
there's a lot of exceptions in the world
like there's seven billion people I know
do you want to talk about every single
one of them or do you think maybe would
you say maybe that's not productive to a
conversation no I feel like maybe
that'll make people realize the extent
of how we don't appreciate certain
things the minimal things you don't you
don't what do you okay what do you mean
by that by the minimal things the small
like the exceptions okay such things as
the okay what do you mean by
appreciating the exceptions like because
like this just sounds like nothing like
we don't bring no awareness we don't
talk about it enough so like what what
exceptions what do we not talk about
just like now we're talking about women
dressing up so we need to we need
there's women that do there's women that
do and we need to bring up Brazil why
because it happens it's acceptable in
that in that place why is it not and why
is it not acceptable it's sort of
acceptable everywhere if you go to the
beaches now not just that Brazilian
women are very very submissive women so
like when it comes to how they treat
their man you can't even come close to
how the Western women treat their men so
that's not even a comparison so you can
let them dress and Shake bum bum because
when they come home that's your ultimate
respect whereas a lot of Western y'all
are coming home and trying to beef their
man
I I find it weird how you guys also
straight away you all said like that's
controlling right and and it is just
like a respect thing like it's not even
like I'm just asking you like why if you
truly love this person and this person
doesn't like that you dress that way
then you should at least for our respect
for the person that you love that is the
lovely for your life at least
willing to do that you know like like
and same the other way around if my wife
told me to do something because I love
and care for her I would do do that as
well like if it really annoyed her would
you guys be cool with your your man
going to the strip club with his boys
yeah yeah I don't mind yeah I'll go with
him no no I'm saying bye
by himself you wouldn't care
I think it's because strip club is like
like most guys don't do anything at a
strip club so I think you have to push
it like
a little further yeah
don't give these girls excuses they're
coping out with their answers We're not
gonna do that a strip club is a club
no no okay go ahead go ahead so you
trust me yeah you girls will say you
don't you don't care but you'll be
blowing up his phone you'd be calling
all your girls you're planning on
Revenge and doing all kind of Madness so
let's keep it up
do you think the strip clubs if if a guy
comes late yo you're already assuming
that he's cheated on you
baby
yeah then that is the majority of
females that are insecure then because a
lot of um relationships are not built on
Trust on our respect
don't you think it's disrespectful to
wear something revealing when you have a
boyfriend uh yeah and no and the reason
why I say yeah can I get yes or no no no
no that's yes or no okay I I bow out
did you say do you think it's respectful
yeah do you think it's respectful when
you have a when you have a man to be
wearing something very revealing that he
wouldn't approve of well I don't I don't
know about his approval or not I would
say that if it was my husband then I
would consider it but if if you're my
boyfriend then I'll decide that I want
to win wait hold on you just say
consider yeah that means that but the
thing is I'm not gonna go out like with
my ass hanging out but um if you're
saying that I just I'm not gonna do
nothing too mad so you're saying that if
he was your boyfriend that you wouldn't
so he should wife you to get comfortable
75 percentage of submissiveness so your
children gets more so yeah
you're showing him what he doesn't want
and then you expect to get better
outcomes by showing him I'm not gonna
listen to you now but put a ring on it
see this is this is we're doing it again
we're doing it again where we say we say
something about women and then we push
it on the men Allah take accountability
I can't take accountability in this
conversation yeah is you're you're
always thinking from your specific lens
yeah the reason a man is telling you not
to behave and dress that way it's
because he knows what other men do
better do yeah but then let's say for
example because I've been in a situation
where I've been with a girl she's
dressed mad and then we've got into an
old occasion because I know boys grabbed
their cheek that could have been
avoidable how she dressed differently
but now I have to punch up her next man
because of stupidness you did when I
could have just told you babes that's a
bit too much but then you're telling me
in potential danger or passing potential
danger as a result
of causing that problems because if he
says don't wear that then you wear it
and there's a problem because of it you
wouldn't say that's on you when he when
he told you that's that's not the man
that wasn't raised right yeah
but it's like it's like there's a
there's a
there's a difference between going into
a situation it's like okay if a dude get
Mo it gets mugged at night because he's
walking alone with a big chain around
his neck do you really feel bad for him
I always feel like Poe you have to go to
extreme with them so you have to say
he's waving it around and then you're
like no you don't feel it
I have to put my jewels in my pocket
I do think it's smart to just leave them
out no okay okay I have expensive camera
equipment okay is it smart for me to go
down to the bad part of London grab my
my nicest camera here and just wave it
around for people and people to take
they probably wouldn't know the value
okay okay can you answer the question
would that be smart would that be smart
well
probably not no okay so could you could
you see from the men's point of view
it's probably not smart to walk around
half naked when you have a man but does
that give him a man the right to touch
you no it doesn't give them the right to
touch you but it's about taking yourself
out of bad situations if you can and
like women walk around the world like
like we're so spoiled we're so spoiled
as women because we're so used to being
protected like men protect us every day
in the world they built the
infrastructure for us okay when someone
is attacking you who do you call
your man well all the police but even if
you call the police you want um
no no you're right you're right so if
you've got like five muggers on you and
two females come up you'll be like what
the [ __ ]
right right what was the question I'm
saying okay men protect us every day
because when you are mugged who would
you call if someone breaks into your
apartment
[Music]
that's what I'm saying men tamed the
world for it used to be Wars all the
time if we go into war who's going the
men
men built the world they protect us and
now we're spoiled to the point we want
to go out of our way to put ourselves in
dangerous situations and and you have to
be like and then we feel entitled to
security sorry sorry no I was gonna say
if you want a good guy as well then you
need to be good as well like if a girl
if you generally want a guy that cares
for you and then you say no I'm gonna
dress in this way like you're just not
gonna get those guys that you're looking
for then I feel like that goes back to
what Pearl was saying about like
um being submit submissive to a guy that
you genuinely like respect I feel like
that comes into play a lot Maybe
being submissive to a guy that you
generally respect could you talk more
about that so say for example like if if
you um respect like your partner or you
value what he has to um say or like say
for example we say that men are leaders
and they're they are meant to lead us to
Greener posture for example like a woman
would kind of look to her partner for
direction in some sort of capacity so if
me
um saying that I value my partner's
decisions and his decision-making and I
and I trust that his decision making
will be in like will be fitting for us
both then I would consider like not
necessarily changing myself but like
some of the decisions that I would make
because it may have a negative impact on
us both and not just affecting him but
when you use the words I would consider
yeah like I don't really it makes me not
really believe you as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible